hey there and welcome to this proflos
quick tip my name is cameron and today
we are talking about
audio and you may say why are we talking
about audio when we're
in a motion design membership i'll tell
you why it's because
we're always or a lot of times working
with audio
and i get asked all the time what's an
easy way to cut down our audio
to a desired length if the audio is not
already cut down to that length so what
i have here is i have an audio track
that is
two minutes and 26 seconds long and you
can see it right here
and i'm in adobe audition and you can do
this in
multiple versions of adobe audition you
do not have to have the newest version
what we're going to do is go to file new
and we want to do multi-track
session we're going to select where we
want to save the file
select the sample rate that we want to
use what we want to call it click ok
and here is our multi-track session all
we have to do now is just
drag our audio onto one of these layers
and you can see here it is i'll zoom out
we have a full length track here
all the way down here to two minutes and
26 seconds long
all you have to do now is just select
the audio track
make sure you click on properties right
here and enable
remix here it's going to do its
analyzing clip
magic takes just a few seconds and now
all i have to do
is here at target duration is i have to
input a value of how long i want my
track to be
so let's say we're going for something
like 30 seconds
i'll type in 30 hit enter and there you
go
we magically have a track that is almost
30 seconds now
a lot of times this is not going to be
exact so if it needs to be exactly 30
seconds you're going to want to type in
a value probably less than 30 seconds
here for a target duration
now we can also go into our advanced
settings here and we can say
hey we need the edit length to be
shorter or longer
we can adjust the features the minimum
loop length which is 8
beats we could select something like 16
beats
something like 4 beats it just depends
on what your audio track is and what
you're trying to do
slack and so on and so forth so a lot of
times
i will keep these values pretty much
in the center here and i don't mess with
beats too often but you can and it still
works really well
and then when we zoom in you can see
here what's actually going on we can see
these little squiggly lines here these
are where the edits are made
based on the the intelligence of
audition looking at this track and
saying okay this is where the edits
could work
really well and if i play it you're
going to hear it sounds pretty seamless
[Music]
so
[Music]
again i could play around with features
like the timber
the harmonics things like that that's
going to adjust how this edits together
so it's always fun to kind of play
around with this kind of these
parameters here and get something more
interesting
and again if i wanted to make this let's
say even
shorter i could type in something like
15
there we go play it back
[Music]
and there you go so it just depends on
the track uh what you can get away with
with the intelligence but for the most
part this is a really
easy super quick way to edit down your
audio to the desired
length that you need
you